[Music]
making Marco Wow's fans with two looks
and two appearances on her
second-to-last day in Africa I never
thought my life would be that awesome
the Duchess kicked off Tuesday by going
back to college stepping out at the
University of Johannesburg in a tan
classic trench dress from Banana
Republic which she paired with beige
Stuart Weitzman pumps the purpose of MMS
visit was to announce a new series of
gender grants from the association of
Commonwealth universities
higher education for women is a cause
Megan holds near and dear and is
something she also highlighted during
her 2008 teen tour of the Pacific the
journey of higher education is an
incredible impactful and pivotal one
next on Megan's Tuesday agenda was a
quick wardrobe change for an appearance
at the charity ActionAid to discuss
gender-based violence the Duchess rocked
yet another trench dress this time a
khaki number from The Canadian holistic
fashion brand room 502 and she was
greeted by a slew of young girls
presenting her with drawings flowers and
even hugs after the meeting the Duchess
travelled privately to meet a number of
young girls who are being supported by
the charity meanwhile Harry is wrapping
up his final day in Malawi for me it's
just as it should be for everybody
everybody else there shouldn't be any
one person or group of people that are
focusing on conservation in the way that
conservation in it's a global issue now
this affects every single one of us the
35 year old royal will return to South
Africa Tuesday night to reunite with
Megan and Archie after five days in
Malawi Botswana and Angola
you